[Music]
in Saved by the Bell news when I wake up
in the morning getting up in the heart
it's an attendant that happy not happy I
didn't know if y'all were in harmony or
if he was trying to win yo not same show
902 uh no Luke Perry you know I don't
know a reboot and what about a pair he
did 902 months I never liked 902 uh no
because I couldn't understand a stroke
did you start liking it in elementary
school or were you older uh I think it
was around elementary school I was in
elementary school I was too dumb to
understand a girl show that one would
they just like rich I never watch TV
yeah oh okay I want to watch the read
with then majority of them done much
Harry was supposed to be rich they were
all pretty much rich except for Brenda
Brenda and Brenda's the more neutral
like this statement what about Felicity
I remember that one I didn't watch that
I didn't like it I'll a Sabrina the
Teenage Witch that was younger yeah that
doesn't I watch they bring they add that
back that's actually there's a new
search term to remember Melrose Place I
didn't like it much that charm was don't
be done the [ __ ] Alyssa Milano dude
that was icon who's the boss and then
she disappeared forever she came back
there and you're like [ __ ] fine
do it now like today I still watch it
because it's nostalgic to me it was such
a bad show but I'm even glued to the TV
because Alyssa Milano's titties are all
nice and chilling
oh she was bad man I like Buffy the
Vampire Slayer she was dr. Michelle
Gellar did you watch the movie with Luke
Perry full circle oh you never watched a
movie that's where it started from the
movie and then it went to show no I just
saw the started I remember angel Buffy
was an angel as though they filmed Buffy
the Vampire Slayer at my friend's school
Torres high school I wanted to put my
stage no we should watch the movie in
honor of all right how do I look bad
pass away too much chips
submitted by bear attacks hmm I feel
like I'm a guest salt angry that I get a
stroke oh then chill the [ __ ] out you
know can't make that serious sorry oh
god show the [ __ ] out to California
knows how to party this governor has
issued a hold on executions oh why you
don't like killing people Joe looks like
an Asian rocky you know before I used to
like when I was a kid and I first heard
about like you should make it huh it's
like it seemed like oh that's what the
government does they're adults that must
be right and then I got older I was like
I didn't really like I don't pay
attention to like political policies and
stuff but like literally just reading
that now I'm like does the government
have the right to take your life no
matter what you do cuz like I don't I
don't know like Texas will fry your ass
in a second yeah you know and that's
just so interesting to me so much that
the government can take your life it's
if we agree that it's right that it's
right for someone's life to be taken if
they've committed a heinous crime
against society okay like what are the
standards on this then because like I
haven't heard of any of the school
shooters that you know ended up getting
executed I guess maybe it's the state
laws or something oh the bathroom break
you shion's and stuff like the hours are
regulated by the state or decided by the
hey but in Florida they do have a death
penalty too so to give you some
statistics there are more than 900
people that have been sentenced to death
in California since 1970 I am dude real
only 13 have been executed since 1978
the other ones doing just rotting away
or another so 79 have died of natural
causes 26 took their own lives and the
rest are just chillin like they're all
the death penalty but they're not
getting dead yeah and so since 1976
Texas has carried out the most
executions with 560 waste money
followed by Virginia with 113 and then
blue because Virginia but then I was
like oh this bad 12 there are two
thousand seven hundred and thirty-eight
inmates on death row in the u.s. today
the death penalty is legal in thirty US
states California has the most prisoners
on death row with 737 [ __ ] dangle no but
they've only carried out 13 since 1976
do we know a paycheck I think they're a
paycheck yeah why would they why would
they execute their money I think each
prisoner costs us like 40,000 per
prisoner a year to have them because I
mean that's for the guard that's for the
housing or like where they stay that's
for their food someone in California the
last time that they executed someone in
California was in 2006 20 Williams I
think so what did he was the leader of
the [ __ ] oh gee crib but he changed his
ways man you made a children's book yeah
he was dude just found that merit it's
like if you're buff you shouldn't be
killed man yeah it's everyone in prison
yeah there's a lot of them I like that
yeah so California Governor Gavin Newsom
has issued a new some new some new some
like noose Newsom oh yeah dude that's
kind of crazy
bringing the panono so he does he issued
a moratorium on execution and a
temporary reprieve for all 737 it's
moratorium it's like a halt
oh why but his name doesn't really work
well for him good well it's Belden you
like something new but why you trying to
hit the pause button I don't understand
why our state absolutely loves criminals
our state [ __ ] they care more about
the criminals than they care about the
citizens that's what's it's so [ __ ]
backwards but even just all-around like
you know that like in Texas they got the
castle law so here if the burglar comes
in and [ __ ] rapes your ass and then as
soon as they turn around you can shoot
at them we have really hard laws to get
acquire firearms to protect ourselves
it's just everything is in the criminals
favor all of our laws they want the
criminals to [ __ ] criminalize or some
[ __ ] yeah but if you rob somebody maybe
triple or something in their house and
you fall on a knife and then you get
sued for it yeah is that that's some
[ __ ] because they want to catch him
and throw them in jail
they cost them $40,000 for it that we
pay as taxpayers our taxpayer money
their allowance just like in school that
hurt I don't know wait but the prisons
make money off the prisoners well if
it's a for-profit prison but at the same
time if it's not a for-profit prison so
there's there's too many prisoners right
there's not enough prisons to house them
there's not enough prisons to keep them
so it's overflowing right
but it's a good Rock it's a it's a good
racket it makes a lot of [ __ ] money
right so if I'm a businessman and I'm
like hey government you guys don't have
enough space for prisoners I'll build
one I'll build a prison and then you
just give me money and then I'll run it
and do everything for you so then these
guys get government is your parent yeah
so they don't use the government they
don't have parents they can't do it they
can't build a prison from scratch they
can't do all that so then they just
license or they spend the money and give
it to private prisons too big they
basically outsource
so it's like that you know what I think
they should do instead of giving people
life they should put people on like
there
sentences like like minimum life which
is like you got to live with like the
bare minimum like you get the shittiest
bread you only get water like like I
mean like cuz I don't know if I should
be able to like kill people but also I'm
like that's also considered cruel and
unusual punishment right but then why
put them in solitary confinement is
killing them not cruel and unusual I
mean it's not punishment but like it's
it's literal I think solitary
confinement is way more cruel well it's
because our because our prisons are
supposed to be for reform you're
supposed to reformat he doesn't and then
a lot of people are like we don't ever
want this person to be like released or
whatever but yeah I don't know it seems
like there's no easy way to go about it
because like they did something the
whole system is is basically it can't be
you changed because a lot of jobs are in
the line not not saying that it should
it be changed it's difficult to change
because a lot of jobs and and there's a
lot of money flowing through well and
the community to like like the the what
is it the low blow budget what is it
called like low income there we go yeah
like low income like cities and stuff
like no one really gives a [ __ ] about
them so even that like even at that
point it starts you're gonna me word
they're getting miss education there's
definitely ways to break the cycle and
make it better but there's no profit in
solutions profit comes from treating
things and not remedies so for example
cancer so so for example a cop came out
and he's no longer a cop anymore but he
was saying like you know the reason why
there's so many arrests that happened in
poor communities and not so much in
affluent communities is because in poor
communities there's a list of things
that you can't arrest people on and
they're a lot easier to arrest because
they don't have lawyers and things like
that and things will go through you'll
boost your resume you'll do it like he's
like check this out and he's patrolling
through a nice upper middle-class
neighborhood he's like look I can't get
anyone on anything like there's no one
hanging out there's whatever as soon as
he goes into like a poor neighborhood
right there's people chillin that's
loitering
he's like pointing it out he's like that
you know he doesn't have his tags
because he
can't afford it you know like he can't
pay for his registration I could exploit
that he's parked illegally he's like
that that and then he's like I could
have a ton of things and then when I go
up there one of those guys might have a
warrant on them one of those guys might
have some type of pocket knife or
whatever I could take him in and then
his record booths because he makes so
many arrests so and then from there this
guy goes to prison right and then the
lawyer the system it's like hey we made
this many arrests this year we book this
many criminals this year so then they
boost that number of their resume the
department the police department the
court system it's like look we made this
many like arrests five hundred better
than last year last year was four
hundred they're a number now everyone
feels safer and better because we made
so many arrests right now the jail
system they like they have all these
people in there and for each each
prisoner that they have they're getting
a budget so for example if that's your
business right why would you want to
decrease the amount of prisoners that's
in your prison if you're getting paid
forty thousand dollars per prisoner
right that means if you decrease the
number of prisoners because you're
bettering the community and in your
stopping crime you have ten thousand
prisoners instead of you're a hundred
thousand prisoners now you got to lay
off all the people that were working
there because you don't have that many
prisoners where are they gonna go now
you got to shut down the prison because
the community is all good what are you
gonna do for your next business or your
next job so it's this [ __ ] up cycle
where it's hard to break because there's
money tied to everything I didn't even
know we had a new governor since when
it's not Arnold recently no Jerry Brown
was yeah was governor after Jerry see I
told y'all should vote Oh God Jerry was
previously a governor and he won again
or some [ __ ] I'm doing that so here's
some photos of San Quentin they have the
gas chambers clothes they have a gak we
have a guest I didn't know that either
and then the lethal injection
it is closed how does the worst cheapest
sign I've ever seen like a printout this
will be temporary
yeah here's like some of the ooh
death chairs yeah so the governor said
this so what's our governor's name
adjust I can remember he blasted me I
don't sound stupid and when did you when
did he Gavin Newton so he ended up
saying so this is one of his campaign
pledges like taking the death penalty
out so he said I do not believe that a
civilized society can claim to be a
leader in the world as long as its
government continues to sanction and
sanction the premeditated and
discriminatory execution of its people
so that's what he said when he was
issuing this executive order that makes
sense yeah good for you Arnold you know
our people
[Music]